je vous remercie de votre présence ce
matin nous allons démarrer cette matinée
de travail
après la réflexion que nous avons mené
les propositions que nous avons faites
sur la politique migratoire
c'était le 16 septembre dernier nous
consacrons donc cette matinée du 30
septembre au code du travail
ce fameux code qui est née au début du
siècle dernier qui n'a cessé de grossir
qui comptait 600 articles en 1974 et
plus de 8000 aujourd'hui on en a apporté
un exemplaire pour ceux qui ne
l'auraient pas encore consulté compulser
donc nous avons interrogé nos adhérents
les républicains par le biais de direct
citoyens 91 % des répondants estiment
que la réforme du code de travail est
une priorité et 37% que la rigidité du
code du travail est un frein à la
reprise économique
c'est pourquoi nous avons souhaité
consacrer cette deuxième matinée
importante des républicains à cette
thématique proposition badinter lyon
caen qui envisage de réformer le code du
travail en profondeur rapport de
l'institut montaigne réputée libérale
rapport de terra nova réputé plutôt
proche du parti socialiste rapport
combrexelle ancien directeur du travail
qui vient de remettre un rapport au
premier ministre dont on ne sait encore
ce qu'il va en faire le diagnostic
semble enfin largement partagé même s'il
reste des irréductibles dans les rangs
de la majorité parlementaire actuelle ou
dans certaines organisations de salariés
la complexité croissante et la rigidité
éprouvée du droit du travail est devenu
un frein à l'emploi à la croissance ou à
la croissance donc à l'emploi pires et
je crois que nous pouvons l'affirmer ce
matin le code du travail est en partie
responsable du haut niveau de chômage
dans notre pays
six millions de personnes inscrites à
pôle emploi c'est un million de plus
depuis la prise de responsabilité de
françois hollande
60000 défaillances d'entreprises l'an
dernier 300 mille offres d'emploi non
pourvues paradoxalement tel est le
triste bilan
alors il faut revisiter le code du
travail
certains pensent même qu'il faudrait
repartir d'une page blanche pour avoir
suivi chaire gérard cherpion l'ensemble
des textes de loi sur ces sujets depuis
trois ans que je suis député je suis pas
loin de le penser
en tout état de cause la règle qui
impose un accord national
interprofessionnel jamais signé par
toutes les parties
puis une transcription dans la loi
toujours sujette à un amendement qui
viennent mécaniquement augmenter le
nombre de pages du code du travail et de
contraintes pour les entreprises cette
règle là est de mon point de vue
totalement à bout de souffle
alors si tout le monde est d'accord pour
réformer le code du travail
reste à savoir comment nos adhérents
toujours à travers direct citoyens ont
commencé à répondre à cette question
ils se sont exprimés à 88% pour que
priorité soit donnée aux accords dans
les entreprises et la première question
que nous nous posons républicain c'est
bien celle là quel code du travail
souhaitons nous aujourd'hui
dit autrement que doit contenir le code
du travail pour concilier efficacement
compétitivité économique et cohésion
sociale à mon avis doit répondre à trois
impératifs le soutien au chef
d'entreprise à bord qui souhaitent créer
développer leurs activités mais aussi
ajuster leur charge y compris salariales
en fonction de leur carnet de commandes
et du contexte concurrentiel dans lequel
il évolue
les près de trois millions et demi
d'entreprises françaises n'ont pas la
même taille ni n'évolue sur les mêmes
marchés
ce qu'elles ont toutes en commun c'est
la soif de compétitivité mais le même
code du travail
deuxième impératif la demande de
sécurisation des salariés elle est
légitime car les salariés représentent
le capital humain de l'entreprise
aspirent comme tout un chacun à de la
stabilité et de la visibilité de bonnes
conditions de travail à une juste
rémunération
elle doit s'accompagner d'un dialogue
adulte avec la direction de l'entreprise
en rapport direct dans les petites
entreprises à travers ses représentants
de préférence et lui et on y reviendra
dans les entreprises de taille plus
importante
troisième impératif le code du travail
doit aussi permettre à ceux qui restent
aux portes des entreprises les jeunes
les chômeurs de longue durée
les seniors d'avoir une chance
d'intégrer où de réintégrer l'entreprise
les rigidités du code sont telles que
nombre de chefs d'entreprise renonce à
embaucher en période de croissance
car qu'ils craignent de pouvoir ne se
séparer de leurs salariés quand
l'entreprise connaît un passage à vide
il y a en effet tous les emplois
détruits
mais il ya aussi cher jean charles tu le
rappelle souvent à l'assemblée nationale
tous les emplois qui ne sont pas créés
dans notre pays
alors partant de là nous avons souhaité
avec eric woerth délégué général au
projet et gérard cherpion sait qu
international en charge de l'emploi vous
proposer trois tables rondes ce matin la
première que j'animerai dans un instant
devra répondre à la question qu'est ce
qui relève de la loi
qu'est ce qui relève de la négociation
la deuxième sera animée par gérard
cherpion l approfondir à ce qui relève
de la négociation collective et abordera
des thématiques lourde le contrat de
travail les modalités de rupture le
temps de travail
très attendus les conditions de travail
parce qu'il n'est pas inutile de revenir
en permanence sur nos fondamentaux nous
aurons le plaisir d'accueillir en milieu
de matinée
luc ferry qui philosophe fera sur la
valeur travail
la troisième table ronde sera animée par
eric woerth lui-même il y sera question
de dialogue social de juges
d'administration et de partenaires
sociaux on vend beaucoup en parler des
partenaires sociaux j'ai prévenu notre
président de la cgpme et notre président
nicolas sarkozy qui a donné une longue
interview dans les échos ce matin
viendra clore le débat vers midi il
s'est exprimé donc dans ce grand
quotidien économique
j'imagine que les uns et les autres
avaient déjà pris connaissance de sa
vision de notre pacte économique et
social et à 12h30
nous vous présenterons la dizaine de
questions qui seront soumises aux
adhérents
comme nous nous sommes engagés dans les
statuts des républicains nous proposons
qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya des matinées
comme celle-là sur lesquels nous
réfléchissons et pour lesquels nous
avons et qui sont à des propositions que
les adhérents des républicains puissent
exprimer directement
donc ce sera d'ici la fin de la semaine
et donc ces questions elles émanent du
document d'orientation qui vous sera
soumis qui a donné lieu à un gros gros
travail et je remercie ici tous ceux qui
ont contribué à la réalisation de ce
document qui comporte de nombreuses
propositions et
va au fond des choses que je crois que
les français nous attendent sur le fond
des choses et sur le comment